>> BAUM: Thank you. These are really great
extensions. Hi. My name is Nick. I'm the Product
Manager on the Extensions Project. And I'd
like to tell you a little bit about the gallery
that we launched yesterday. So first, let
me close down some of these tabs. And I'm
also going to head over and uninstall Aaron's
extension. Not because I don't like it, but
because I have a secret plan. Let me go ahead
and do that. And now, let me go to our gallery.
So, let's search for gopher. We weren't lying.
Here is Aaron's extension. It's getting pretty
good ratings. So, maybe I should report it
as spam now for having a fake description,
but actually what I'm going to do is I'm going
to try to install it, and there we go. So,
I promise that this isn't because we had someone
behind the scene is furiously approving this.
Actually, we think that one of the great strengths
of our gallery is that most approval for most
extension is absolutely automatic. So you
don't need to set away around for one of us
to go and check on it. Now, of course there's
still extensions that might be abusive and
so if we receive a report about that, we'll
go and take it down. Same thing if an extension
violates our terms of service, we'll go and
take it down. But the nice thing is you don't
have to wait for us when you post your extension.
You can just get it live right away. There
are a couple of exceptions to this policy
namely: extensions that use native code and
extensions that access the file system. Now,
for security purposes, we do send those to
manual review. But this review is as simple
as signing a copy of our terms and sending
that into us. We've seen very few extensions
uses so far. So I think it's a testament to
the flexibility of the system already. And
when those we have seen have gotten approved
very, very quickly. So we think that this
is really a big game for developers. As you
saw, you can write an extension for five minutes.
You can get it up in a minute. And start distributing,
start testing, and start getting users. The
second thing I'd like to tell you about today
is a little bit about how to make your extension
successful in the gallery. We think there
are three things you can do to make your extension
really do very well. First one, of course,
is to build a great extension. The second
one is to pay attention to how this extension
shows up in the gallery. And the last one
is to promote that extension yourself. So,
let's go through those in order. Building
a great extension, that one is pretty obvious.
At Google we're very focused on the user.
We think that the products have best meet
the needs of the user, at the end of the day
win. And we think the same applies for extensions.
And in fact, we'll be tweaking our ranking
algorithms and the extensions we featured
to constantly try to give an edge to those
extensions that are helping users to really
browse the Web and enjoy the Web better. The
second one is about making your appearance
in the gallery as good as possible. I will
illustrate with an example. So, let me pull
up an extension that I find particularly pretty
here, which is the glue extension. The glue
extension allows you to get social recommendations
for movies, books, music, and other media.
And you'll notice that this looks a little
bit different from Aaron's extension, which
Aaron I'm sure will polish his up later on.
You'll see that we've made it incredibly easy
to actually make a very beautiful extension
page. We let you add large screenshots. We
let you add a description and we even let
you add YouTube videos. We think this last
feature adding a YouTube video is going to
be particularly useful for extensions, because
it's often hard to explain exactly what an
extension does without showing it in action.
And you can do this right on your detail page.
Another thing I'd like you to notice on this
gallery page on this detail page is a little
section here in the corner on the blue background.
We all notice here is that they have a very
nice colorful logo. And they have a short
description that very clearly states what
their extension is going to do and doesn't,
and actually avoids any kind of marketing
speak. Now, the reason this is so important
is that this information is what shows up
in search results and as you browse through
the gallery. And so, this is really what the
user bases their decision to click in your
extension on. And by keeping this as clear
as possible, that leads you standout among,
you know, a field of extensions. The last
part of promoting your--of making your extension
successful is to promote it. Now, of course,
as a Chrome Extensions Team, we're going to
do our very best to promote all the great
extensions you write. So, we have featured
extensions, we have top picks, we're going
to do a video in blog post, and many more
things. But we also encourage all developers,
such as yourselves to go out and promote the
extensions to the channels that you have available
to you. One example of that that I think is
great is promoting your Chrome Extension to
users of Chrome that visit your Website. And
with that that does is gives you a starting
user base unless you start rising in our rankings
and then that in turn makes us even more likely
to want to showcase you. So we think if you
do these three things: build a great extension,
really polish its appearance in the gallery,
and then start promoting in, then you'll have
a really good chance of having success, and
we think that's a really great opportunity.
So, let me also speak for you that today will
not the first day of extensions we've been
working publicly for a while. It's the first
day that we're out in the open for our beta
users, but it's by no means the last day for
extensions. We've got a lot of exciting things
going forward. First obvious one is Mac support.
In fact, extensions already work on the latest
Chromium build. So the latest open source
builds of extensions of Mac have extensions.
And we expect that later this week, we will
ship a dev build with extensions enabled on
Mac, and then extensions will come to Mac
beta and it's stable in early 2010. The second
part is internationalization. Chrome is already
available in more than 40 languages. And we
have a lot of users internationally. And we
want to make it just as easy for extension
developers to reach our international users
as it is for us. We hope that a lot of you
will take advantage of this functionality,
which again will be coming in Q1. Finally,
we're going to be adding lots of APIs. I expect
that for every subsequent major release of
Chrome, we will have a new set of APIs for
you to play with. Now, we have some ideas.
We want to add more UI surfaces. We want to
add, say, keyboard shortcuts, maybe some way
to interact with network request. But at the
end of the day, we're looking for your feedback
to tell us what you want and what's missing
to create your next great idea. And as we're
open source, just join us on the mailing list,
submit any idea, submit a proposal, or even
come help us implement it. So to finish, we've
been out now one day. When we first launched
we had about 300 extensions. The last I checked,
I think we're up to 480. We're hoping we can
have 500 by the end of today. Actually, we
must be at 481 by now at least. And so, we've
been really happy with the reception we've
seen so far. As Brian mentioned at the beginning,
we find extensions incredibly important to
the future of Google Chrome and we're hoping
that if you are a user, you'll go out and
try one of the many extensions we have available.
And if you are a developer, you come up with
your next awesome idea and build it for Chrome.
Thank you.
One last thing, now, of course, you're welcome
to grab something to drink and eat. We've
also set up a few conference rooms around
this area where the demolers [PH], so Xmarks
and eBay and Google Translate will be around
to showcase their extension and chat with
you guys. So, feel free to go find them. Also,
all the extensions team members are here.
We're wearing these shirts. Come find us.
We're really excited to talk to you all.
[END]